open your eyes real wide close real
tight
they are the fundamental movements we
all take for granted
but one's joe dimeo is now having to
relearn
double vision at all when you look side
to side his face
and hands used to belong to someone else
which means everything from blinking
to gripping is once again entirely new
great squeeze my fingers really tight
in an interview with sky news the 22
year old from new jersey
explained what it's like to undergo such
a dramatic
transformation i have to relearn
everything
you know so like when a baby is born
all it does is plays with toys and you
know just keeps moving his hands around
so
that's exactly what i have to do i just
got to keep moving my hands
this is what joe used to look like
before a car crash nearly ended his life
two years ago
the burns he suffered were horrific
multiple skin grafts and reconstructive
surgeries
unable to restore his vision nor the use
of his hands
dozens of doctors were involved in the
transplant operation in new york which
took 23 hours
the procedure has only ever been
attempted twice before
but neither time successful having come
out the other side
joe says he's never looked back i kind
of just you know i just kind of jumped
right into it
i saw my face at first i was like this
is this is me now
and i just i just kind of went with it
that's to put it mildly
less than six months on he's already
practicing his golf swing
his doctors are understandably excited
this confirms to us that we can
transplant this amount of tissue
reliably and safely
with great success this this provides a
great deal of hope
for so many patients that we get to
evaluate in our clinics that we would
tell them there's nothing that we could
do
for joe it's the little things that now
count for a lot like being reunited with
his dog buster
who seemingly didn't notice a change i
guess he recognized the smell
of me because he just he ran right to me
out of everyone in the room
he went straight for me and it felt
really nice to you know actually feel
his fur for the first time
to stop his body rejecting the
transplants joe will be on medication
for the rest of his life
and while his focus now is to build up
physical strength
the mental challenges he's faced have
been arguably
more demanding iva bennett sky news